buenas tardes como comentabas los
aliados han decidido que van a seguir
reforzando la ayuda a ucrania y que ésta
incluso va a aumentar se va a seguir
aumentando el envío de armas también han
de ayuda humanitaria y también equipo
especial por ejemplo para hacer frente a
ataques químicos y biológicos ha
asegurado el secretario general de la
otan jens stoltenberg así como ataques a
la ciberseguridad porque ahora mismo
según la otan lo que se teme es que
rusia se está reagrupando también
rearmando para movilizarse y sobre todo
concentrarse en la región del donbass
porque el objetivo es controlar esta
región del este de ucrania aún así la
alianza advierte que esto no significa
que el presidente de rusia vladimir
putin no quiera controlar a todo el país
por ello también como comentaba
ha acudido a esta reunión el canciller
ucraniano dmitro culé va que ha sido muy
vocal con sus demandas ha asegurado que
lo que entran ya son armas armas y más
armas porque lo que está haciendo un
cráneo no sólo defender al país sino a
todo a europa y que de hecho ellos están
luchando por los ucranianos y también
por los europeos para evitar una
escalada del conflicto también ha
advertido culeba que en todo caso la
situación es muy está muy deteriorada en
el país que están muy preocupados porque
creen que las imágenes de muchas son
sólo la punta del iceberg y que la
situación puede estar aún peor en
ciudades como por ejemplo mariupol pero
también que esto puede deteriorarse aún
más por ejemplo en el este de ucrania si
pues la alianza ha asegurado que es
momento de reforzar esta ayuda a ucrania
y de hecho el secretario de el
secretario general stoltenberg ha
asegurado que es importante en seguir
enviando equipamiento militar de hecho
recordemos república checa y ha enviado
incluso tanques soviéticos al país